قضى الطفل نوح أسابيعه الأولى
بمفرده ، خضعت للفحص المبكر في
سبعة أسابيع وآخر في الأسبوع العاشر في
كلتا المرتين رأوا فيه هذا الطفل الصغير
هناك وكان طفلًا واحدًا فقط حتى
انضمت إليه أخت صغيرة في الرحم ذات يوم
ظهرت روزالي واحدة وثلاثة أطفال لأول مرة على
الموجات فوق الصوتية في الأسبوع 12.
أمي ريبيكا وأبي ريس الذين يعيشون في
إنجلترا فوجئوا تمامًا
بما حدث هو أنني حملت
بينما كنت حاملًا بالفعل ،
وكان ذلك مجنونًا تمامًا عندما أخبرونا
لأن هذا  لم يكن من المفترض أن يحدث ذلك
عندما سمعت أنه لا بد أنك
صُدمت ، لم أستطع أن أصدق ما
حدث لي ،
لكن حدث ذلك ، لقد حملت روزالي الجميلة بعد
حوالي
ثلاثة أسابيع بعد نوح
بتوأم شقيق مثل نوح وروزالي ،
وعادة ما يتم إطلاق بيضتين في
نفس الوقت  الوقت
المخصب وزرع الأجنة
في الرحم في نفس الوقت
في حالة ريبيكا تم إطلاق بيضتين على بعد
ثلاثة أسابيع
كل جنين يزرع في الرحم
بشكل منفصل ، إنه أمر غير معتاد
في هذه الحالة ، يبدو أن المرأة
قد أباضت مرة واحدة لطفل أكبر
ثم فيما بعد لطفل أصغر
يسمى Superfitation وجدت دراسة أجريت عام 2008
أقل من 10 حالات مسجلة في
العالم لريبيكا ، ربما
ساعدها حقيقة أنها كانت تأخذ
عقاقير الخصوبة
بناءً على تاريخ استحقاق نوا ،
وُلِد التوأمان قبل ستة أسابيع تقريبًا من
نوح بسعر أربعة أرطال وعشرة أوقية روزالي جنيهان
وسبعة أونصات
على إنستغرام ريبيكا يوثق تطورهما
بعد البقاء في وحدة العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة
كلاهما في صحة جيدة
ستبتسم من أجله  أنا نعم ،
أنت روزالي من محبي الهواتف المحمولة وميكي
ماوس
نوح ، ربما ليس كثيرًا اليوم ، فهم
بالتأكيد معجبين ببعضهم البعض
بالتأكيد يتواصلون مع بعضهم البعض كثيرًا ،
لذا هل تفكر ريبيكا في نوح
وروزالي
كتوأم أو أخ أكبر وأصغر
أخت ، أنا بالتأكيد أفكر فيهم على أنهم
توأمان
ولدوا في نفس الوقت ،
ربما لم يتم تصورهم
في نفس الوقت ولكني ما زلت
أحملهم في  في نفس الوقت
، لقد ولدا في نفس الوقت ، لذا
نعم ،
إنهما توأمان إليزابيث كوهين.